Hi guys welcome back to our third and
final video on this agile working series.
You are on the English Online Business
English series where we’re equipping
you with the skills and tools needed to
navigate that English speaking workplace.
Today we’re focusing on agile working space.
Now, the vast majority of us have seen some
huge changes to our workspace over the past
couple of years. Going from this, to this.
Having an agile work space is not only about being
able to choose working in the office or remotely,
or having flexible hours, but also about
choosing and moving around the spaces as we work.
Let’s stop there guys and do a
little breakdown of the language.
Today, we’re looking at correlative conjunctions.
We know that conjunctions combine two sentences
or clauses, parts of your sentence together.
A correlative conjunction does this
except we have two phrases, for example:
“Both”, “and”. I like both apples
and bananas. From today, “not only”,
“but also”. Agile work is not only about
flexible hours, but also about flexible space.
So, what does your work space look like?
You might think that it’s easier to implement
an agile working space working from home,
but that’s not always the case, and the
same principles apply to the office.
You need to think about what works for you.
Office spaces are changing. We now may have areas
to sit and relax, sofas to have coffee, maybe you
have hot-desking opportunities, or a chance to
work in the local library.
There’s more importance being focused
now on employee value, input, and emphasis
being placed on employee satisfaction.
What space works for you? When
are you the most productive?
Thanks for watching guys, I hope you
enjoyed our series for agile work.
If you haven’t managed to see the previous videos,
then subscribe to our channel below where you can
keep up to date with all of our great content.
If you haven’t checked out the other videos
on things like conflict management, or
tips for interviews, you can check them
out by clicking on the link that you see here.
Thanks for watching guys, I’ll see you next time!